and then you are registered for our
less classy English courses now you
have to learn to navigate our
portal
you must have received an e-mail asking you
to create a username
and password
once created go to  the link
that was sent to you
here is the number of credits you have
left one credit representing an
hour and a half course as you see there dead
and 6 before booking your classes click
on class kalenda to look at the
available classes you can put a
star to indicate the classes that
interest you click on find cross
to book your classes here you can
filter your search to find
classes that match your
schedule in the event of confinement
selected my class online to
view the courts available online
by clicking  on stoke hull and you
will only see the courses that you have
star and I am only free
in the evenings on Mondays and Fridays and
I do not have  I don't want to see the classes
I've already taken so I tick not taken
monday friday and the hours I'm
available here are the classes that correspond
to my selection
most function it seems to be super
interesting I can see more  details
by clicking on it
it's at 7 p.m. this Monday it's
perfect I'm free reserved use
the search function to find
the courses associated with the theme of your
choice or to find the courses given
by a teacher that you particularly appreciate
I  want to improve my
professional English so I'm going to enter
business for you have booked your
lessons for an entire month you can
view your timetable by
navigating to my dashboard and
clicking on the calendar icon if
for some reason you cannot  can't
attend your court you can
cancel up to 24 hours in advance by
clicking on fears at bug km
don't forget to go to mike soir
estrie to access free activities
é at your court it's always better
to do them one or two hours after the
court to properly integrate what you
have learned and finally you can follow
your progress by clicking on my
progress here you will be able to
view the notes of your evaluations
that  it often makes us feel good to see
how much we have progressed that's all
said we can't wait to see you in
class bye